ya que les dijo que votará por maicon
mientras que la opción fue claro
diciendo que ni un solo voto puede ir a
lópez pero según el sondeo de francia
insumisa que es el partido de milán son
son más los que optan por la abstención
para esta segunda vuelta que los que
apoyan a mccall que tanto puede
favorecer al epen y afectar al
mandatario esta tendencia
pues efectivamente los botones de melón
son tienen un poco la clave de esta
segunda vuelta o algo por lo menos en
gran parte
normalmente se van a dirigir más hacia
macro que hacia los ven pero con una
buena proporción que puede efectivamente
más bien abstenerse o votar en blanco
cosa que evidentemente pues no no
ayudaría mucho a macro en esta segunda
vuelta bueno y por otra parte sólo se me
pidió votar por lópez cuáles son las
posibilidades reales de que la extrema
derecha llegue al elíseo
si efectivamente pues el mar contiene a
priori más reserva de votos que el pp
puede contar básicamente sobre
los botones de ese muro de otro pequeño
candidato de derecha nicola tipo opinión
y los demás en general pues han tenido
más bien hayan llamado más bien a votar
por macro pero pues la cuestión acá es
hasta qué punto esos votantes se iban a
movilizar por macro aunque de todos
modos es bastante impopular tiene una
imagen de candidato de las élites de
candidatos de los ricos que hace que
muchos electores particularmente los más
jóvenes o los electores de los sectores
populares ésta esté muy hondo viendo un
poco está esta segunda vuelta entonces
es
de todos modos una segunda vuelta que es
mucho más apretada de lo que fue la
versión de 2017 en que macro no tenía
realmente una ventaja bastante fuerte
con respecto al open y las encuestas
indican que todavía pues ganaría pero
pues con un margen ya mucho más estrecho
bueno y si revisamos los tres lugares
que siguen son extremos ya sea a la
izquierda oa la derecha con melanson
concedió que tanto un programa de centro
como lo vende de alguna manera emanuel
marco los representa
es una buena pregunta además pues eso va
a depender también de las legislativas
no el sistema francés es un poco raro
tienen 22 vueltas de presidenciales y
después dos vueltas de legislativas y
pues finalmente una tendencia va a tener
que llenar todas las todas esas cuatro
vueltas para poder imponerse incluso si
macro un ken a esta segunda vuelta pues
no está asegurado de tener una mayoría
para poder aplicar su programa después
de pronto va a tener después que hacer
alianzas sea la izquierda sea la derecha
como se lo permite su posición de centro
y eso pues podría
cambiar ciertos aspectos de su programa
de sus propuestas inclinando las hacia
un campo hacia otro todavía pues en el
caso del joven sería aún más difícil
gobernar del después si de en el caso de
ganar la segunda vuelta porque además en
el modo de elección de las legislativas
en frost o en el francés entonces
favorece a su partido que no tiene una
implantación tan tan tan fuerte en todo
el país una base que se espera de lope y
de macon en el debate de este miércoles
sabemos que es una cita muy importante
efectivamente mañana entonces hay un día
que no ha habido debate en la primera
vuelta
cliente candidato se ha dicho que no ha
puesto mucha atención a esta compañía
por esto pues aparece un poco en
dificultad finalmente llegó a la cabeza
en estas elecciones pero con un
porcentaje de todos modos todavía
bastante bastante ajustado entonces ésta
está esta cita g del debate de segunda
vuelta va a ser muy importante en 2017
macro había ganando fácilmente está esto
este debate frente al joven que estaba
menos preparada macro venía de ser
ministro de de ser ministro de hacienda
entonces eso lo ayudaba mucho tenía un
mejor conocimiento ahí como presidente
de pnc como presidente saliente también
tiene una una ventaja en el conocimiento
de las grandes preguntas de los grandes
dossier que
que sé que se van a tratar pero pues
también tiene la desventaja de ser que
sería conocido y de tener en contra suya
pues aparte del electorado que no apoya
su política entonces en este sentido
pues va a la va a tener un poco más
difícil porque va a tener que convencer
la gente que que no hay
apreciado su primer mandato